jamie lynn spears shows off a gift from
her sister britney spears to her
daughters
amid brits ongoing conservatorship
battle
and the pop star's declaration that she
wants to sue her family during her
testimony last month
jamie lynn posted this pic of a box
filled with a purse
and stuffed animals on her insta story
sunday
sharing that they were gifts for her two
daughters thirteen-year-old maddie whom
she shares with her ex
casey aldridge and three-year-old ivy
whom she shares with her husband
jamie watson the actress tagged britney
and
wrote alongside the snap quote nothing
sweeter than coming home to a box
full of goodies for my girls from their
auntie the post comes a few days after
the 30 year old former nickelodeon star
shared
this screenshot of a headline reading
britney spears's sister jamie lynn
shares photos of her home life after
it's revealed she is the only family
member
not on singer's payroll i am now ready
to
tell the story at the time jamie lynn
added quote
facts now leave my broke ass alone she's
10 years younger than me but she's like
so stubborn and she's like so headstrong
and she makes me laugh
she's hilarious britney's money and who
has access to it has been a hot topic of
discussion
the new york times revealed last month
that every month brittany's dad
jamie spears gets 16 thousand dollars
plus two thousand dollars for rent for
an office
and per the new yorker her mom lin and
brother brian
also get money from the entertainer in
documents obtained by e.t
last year the stronger singer paid her
attorneys and team of advisors
over 1.2 million dollars in 2019
and that same year her dad received 128
000 as a conservator
it's a very big deal that she's speaking
out and she has told
the court she wants her voice heard
britney appeared remotely before a judge
on june 23
to address the court directly with an
explosive testimony
slamming her family and requesting to
terminate the 13-year-long
conservatorship
without being evaluated this marked the
first time in years that brittany spoke
in court about the conservatorship
which has been extended until september
2021.
she's come to a head and she needs to
figure out what she's going to do about
this conservatorship
and she thinks this is the best way to
get her point across
under the conservatorship the pop star
claims she has been forced to take
birth control and says she is not
allowed to ride in her boyfriend
sam eskari's car she also stated that
she would like to
sue her family i think it's extremely
clear that the day i was born i've only
loved adored and supported my sister
i mean this is my freaking big sister
before any of this bull
after britney's testimony jamie lynn
took to her instagram story
insisting that she has her sisters back
my sister knows i love and support her
that's the only person i owe anything to
i'm not my family i'm my own person i'm
speaking for myself
i'm so proud of her for using her voice
i'm so proud of her for requesting new
counsel like i told her to do many years
ago
the former zoe 101 star also shut down
the haters who criticized her for not
speaking out publicly sooner
maybe i didn't support her the way the
public would like me to
with a hashtag on a public platform but
i can assure you that i've supported my
sister
long before there was a hashtag and i'll
support her long after and
jamie lynn says ultimately she just
wants her big sister to live a happy
life
if ending the conservatorship find mars
or whatever the hell else
she wants to do to be happy
i support that 100
because i support my sister i love my
sister always have always will
as long as she's happy
you